is there still a chance for peace in
Syria in the interview leader of the
Syrian government in exile off matome a
donor is hello mr. prime minister can
you describe the atmosphere of your
talks with German Foreign Minister
frank-walter Steinmeier callicott hanma
Raja it was a very earnest and honest
meeting the hangman calleja and as the
clermont our discussion made clear that
our German friends are very concerned
about the well-being of the Syrian
people yes I'm su tela but they want
Syrians to live in security and Germany
has put a lot of effort into
international diplomacy to come to a
proper solution for the Syrian people in
Germany brought up a number of points
during the talks which they hope will
bring both sides of the conflict closer
together that includes whether we're
prepared to make compromises even
painful ones on issues that Germany
believes could be key to a solution and
better for Syrians in the long term
fattah karimi TJ Yeldon masala ha ha
assudem stop now and look after Donna
visual and what sort of compromises and
she and I cannot e at the satellite know
regarding one of the core problems how
far were prepared to accept compromises
on the transitional government SSE yeah
Elmo Judah Hallion well as you know we
as the national coalition and government
in exile had the courage to accept the
invitation of un secretary-general ban
ki-moon to the second Geneva Conference
name of called ability with you hey Lena
we brought up three main issues there
that Yankee Mon who fought the
implementation of Kofi Annan six-point
plan boo notice it difficult the
transition from tyranny to democracy in
Syria csec cydia and honda moradabad
adam hollister and the creation of a
transitional government with full
executive powers including command of
security forces secret services and the
army Yeshua Jesus lista para jemima
faceted don't hey yo yo anukunna just
welcomed into poly that transitional
government should be formed by consensus
and the opposition and regime should
both play a role well the cotton gin no
shuja to ballina another pop it was
courageous of us to accept that and
reach a compromise let see my profile
and I mama I said love the lib rahimi
the problem facing locked our Ebrahimi
now and which mr. Steinmeier mentioned
is this and then wat de la we don't see
President Bashar al-assad as part of the
solution or part of any transitional
government shaking the Lashkar a new
cannabis shall I said but the regime
insists on it Carly Bannerman navami
osoto eleniak on Bashar Assad resumen
just my documents we're asked if it's
completely out of the question huh how
do you get on to [ __ ] you or if it's
something we'd acquiesce to in the
search for a compromise but our position
is clear enough you had the Ambassador
Bashar al-assad under no circumstances
will ever be accepted by us as a
dwelling in willoughby after all the
destruction and death that he's brought
down upon the Syrian population we could
heatherton me in the Shah bisutti lean
on Janna Malamud imagine if had this one
back to the Geneva Conference and the
formation of a transitional government
missoula la muralla at this future
government in exile play a part in that
or what its role be over entonces con
una semana de atacama lente pallium an
ascent ahead I'll hakumen mahkota man
Okinawa boom Salvador we've made clear
that our only concern is the well-being
of the Syrian people also relative
happen if we agree on a transitional
government in Geneva then the government
in exile will be subject to its will
that the sort of adjustment have we need
to find this is not about keeping our
posts articles if there is an agreement
will stick to it might emit also latifah
we committed to the second Geneva
Conference from the very start because
we believe it's in the interest of the
Syrian people and to kar dena be a
mustache I bisutti who off you had a
teacher that is Ailin engine evening
after two rounds of talks no date has
been set for a third do you think
negotiations are still possible or is
Geneva 2 over as many observers believe
manager named named cadenza hakama yard
alladi gmail maracas me and I didn't
okay a majority only let's assess the
first two rounds of
goshi ations Lathon on politically we
believe we achieved a number of things
we showed the world that we want a fair
political solution and Helen see how the
regime wants to stall so they can
continue killing than afford her lunacy
SEO no pathetic why else would they drop
barrel bombs on civilians holy UT this
regime has rejected every initiative its
governing principle is Assad or we'll
burn the country either we rule or kill
you in mckennitt shadow who al-assad I'm
not repeal valid Raja Rojo enough to
loco moco moco and then hadith louder ll
Akuma go so what is your task as a
government the government coming out of
the National Coalition chocolate banana
anakapalli telefono ah Tony algerie any
maha maha beaucoup muhammad yunus the
fundamental task we're facing is
improving the living conditions of
people in liberated parts of Syria that
includes humanitarian aid education
healthcare and other relief measures
that also goes for region still under
regime-controlled we want to better
people's lives in all parts of Syria and
we want to be a government for all
Syrians not just some of them kanako
metallically serene well II said Leo's a
menace ori ki Fateh cumbia del medico
how do you propose to do that in
regime-controlled areas home indeed a
chameleon with a kid no no no Fiona we
can't deny the fact that even in
liberated areas we have huge problems
cameta an alumna no region is spared
from the government's bombardments
medina jamaat and what the thought
iphone what they should do that and we
also have to deal with extremist groups
especially the ISIS who are cutting our
supply lines to the cities well its
opponent of a messiah kuvira well I can
I letter on my end but that doesn't mean
we're not doing anything I'm up to feed
ID no boku no joke at all levels were
making every effort to give people an
income and better their living
conditions asylee whether it's clearing
rubble shin or providing emergency
shelter passing a little fee him mama
deal Emily feudal here once I don't hot
the famous out of an alkali defilement
whenever a barrel bomb is dropped
somewhere we
coordinate with local councils to see
how we can clear the rubble and ease the
suffering is that having a father of her
had the Messiah vocabulary t about after
her shock so did hadith and
jamaat-e-islami awaken publish the
National Coalition says they represent
the people America and bethought oh man
Anita laughing oh but what about other
opposition groups mahua motive like the
National Coordination Committee and the
Syrian National Council had conceived
Obama mrs. Logan is soo Lee Alex Avila
me feel invincible the National Council
is a fundamental component of the
coalition assalamu but they have
different positions on geneva can have
the elephants Boehner those are
differing opinions among siblings but
they can't be resolved [ __ ] myself it's
a holiday I believe will soon put those
differences aside we've repeatedly
offered to cooperate with the
Coordination Committee in our
fundamental areas of common ground and
miss Eva so the overthrow of the regime
and no future role for Assad and natasha
poly huh well he estado novo while they
couldn't appear in contact with them
through the coalition can was talk much
and almost reached an agreement affinity
laughs ma home and we believe that any
future discussions and negotiations will
have a reasonable outcome a that's
benefiting of all that you can untie
them if you hadn't Monica Chatwin for
that when I were to fail be an Olympian
and a serenity jamarco none LOL have you
thought at the moment we're witnessing
infighting between Islamist groups like
Isis the al-nusrah front and the Islamic
Front do you share the view that
Islamist groups dominate on the ground
in Syria lalala I'm a man on a
calculator comet Allah and a shabbos
Roberto brt shabam what I did the Syrian
people are fundamentally moderate and
reject extremism and violence thorensen
mia when y la jolla dr hawala linty
Parliament Marcus enmity yamaha the
resolution began peacefully had a shop
but the regime forced the people to
become militantly medaille Xuan you
shaky new hot or unhappy and ali shah
bleep Syrians know that Isis represents
a danger to the country Jamaat and not
just because of the fighting with other
groups
10 min and Jason hood had image mods the
original components of the popular free
syrian army stood against extremists and
force them out of in lib aleppo makeba
and Daris or hoses on FEMA not a play it
live woman attack which is a monitor
Halliburton team half of the desert then
it had the Thunder coach about most
remarkable you spoke about Isis but not
the nusrah front which some countries
have also labeled a terrorist group oh
man injam a teen so and dodge does your
government see any difference between
the two very confident female vania
business materially jabatan Aslam
allahabad and the more the biggest
extremists with the new Seraph front
have gone over to Isis especially the
foreigners well cool and muhajireen
leaving someone office they subscribe to
radical views that are mainly directed
against Syrians well have been no not
that would you had to know that's why
Isis isn't fighting the regime shabbos
whenever they want to subjugate the
Syrian people first before they turn
against the regime that via Geneva went
to Toronto Sofia shabba we have no
relations with the news front we're in
agreement with international opinion
what Anna's on do their followers have
to first give up those extreme ideas
that have led to their international
isolation even actually had them at the
snake for home finished am i ee island
home much mods be had a shaky so i love
here the item a little man but the image
you've called for moderates in the
nusrah front to join the free syrian
army but many of the fsa's commanders
like Salim Idris and Riyadh al-assad
reject that call Alan home Anastasia
Bullock said what does it mean for the
Free Syrian Army kaif italiana Nadia
Colorado Mahal so to a thorough Burma
Lavinia to judge to have not know how
the finale's SE and you [ __ ] Hanukkah
Joshua Nolan our goal is a unified Free
Syrian Army with a regular military
command acceptable to everyone of when
an elitist Roswell and Azad well an
original Muzzy them in that we don't
want any more disputes read and you can
have the g xu j chinois we want an army
that
change the balance of power either
against regime forces or Isis lateral so
a phylogeny la illaha hottie probably me
do at least let me a fedora that's the
only way that our government can gain
leverage and improve its negotiating
position my team or karate a woman is a
rocket your eyes is a mocha film follow
the cs without a unified army which
excludes the extremists we won't be able
to achieve anything not this regime will
continue to dream about ruling Syria and
dream about returning people to the
oppression of the past 50 years since
ebcs you have an alarm lamp in wanna be
a chicken mascot and it's Halle and hold
me hey if we can achieve unity we can
achieve great things win the duel
banoffee human Lujan cinnamon and then I
talk a lot defense of an AHA kahuna
Taliban daughter thank you for the
interview I Yakima I know it's Anna